dass soziale medien wie facebook und co
alle wirklich alle daten über ihre
nutzer sammeln ist nichts neues
doch auch diejenigen unter euch die
nichts mit solchen plattformen armut
damals auch gar nicht angemeldet sind
sind vor diesen daten kragen ganz und
gar nicht sicher
ein forschungsteam aus der schweiz hat
nun konkrete hinweise auf sogenannte
schatten profile gefunden und ja ihr
habt richtig vorhersagen über sehr
private details wie zum beispiel
sexuelle interessen oder aktueller
beziehungsstatus sind damit möglich und
zwar von nichtnutzern wie social media
nutzer also die privatsphäre derjenigen
preis geben die offline leben und wofür
genau auch vielleicht eure daten
missbraucht werden könnten
jetzt klingt zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
man könnte manchmal fast denken dass
facebook noch vor einem selbst weiß
welche personen man gut finden welches
neue hobby man demnächst ausprobieren
möchte oder welche reise als nächstes
ansteht teilweise ist das schon fast
unheimlich wie gut soziale medien ihre
nutzer kennen und natürlich auch kein
stück verwunderlich bei den ganzen
daten die man bei sozialen medien wie
facebook und co über sich selbst
preisgibt privatsphäre hd möchte man
das nicht und seine daten schützen
meldet man sich eben nicht an so könnte
man meinen das stimmt aber nicht
denn was von uns im internet bekannt ist
entscheiden wir längst nicht mehr
selbst sondern diejenigen in unserem
freundes und bekanntenkreis die sozialen
medien nutzen 2013 ist dass allen das
erste mal richtig klar geworden da
musste facebook eine riesige
sicherheitslücke eingestehen oder ich
sag mal ein feature konkret konnten user
an die kontakte von nicht freundin
gelangen es war sogar noch krasser
selbst telefonnummern und
e-mail-adressen von leuten die noch
niemals bei facebook angemeldet gewesen
waren wurden teilweise preisgegeben und
für facebook ist es keine kunst an die
daten von nichtnutzern zu gelangen
im gegenteil denn alle die facebook den
zugriff auf ihre persönlichen e mail
dienste erlauben geben diese kontakte
frei facebook lädt sich dann die
digitalen telefonbücher seiner nutzer
herunter dieses phänomen also wenn
informationen über nicht nutzer
gesammelt werden nennen experten eben
schatten profile und genau dazu hat
jetzt ein forscher aus der schweiz
weitere brisante hinweise gesammelt
für seine studie hat er die plattform
namens friends tagen und sie ist zwar
stillgelegt unzählige accounts lassen
sich aber weiterhin im archiv
analysieren hier wollte er herausfinden
ob sich aussagen über leute treffen
lassen die dort nicht angemeldet sind
und die antwort lautet ganz klar ja in
seinem experiment analysiert in der
forschung zum beispiel inwiefern
bestimmte persönliche merkmale vom
fenster usern mit denen ihrer kontakte
zusammenhängen beispielsweise fand er
so heraus dass heterosexuelle er mit dem
jeweils anderen geschlecht in kontakt
stehen homosexuelle vernetzen sich
dagegen häufiger mit nutzern die
dasselbe gewicht haben die sie selbst so
entstanden
in seiner studie statistische musste
natürlich für weitere unterschiedliche
faktoren und diese wiederum würden es
in diesem fall bei fenster erlauben
relativ unkompliziert ein schatten
profil zu konstruieren von einer person
die eben kein nutzer ist relativ
treffsicher könnten antworten auf
fragen wie wie ist die sexuelle
orientierung von personen xy oder wie
ist der beziehungsstatus von personen xy
beantwortet werden sehr intime
informationen also die die menschen
wahrscheinlich lieber für sich behalten
würden die treffsicherheit für solche
aussagen stieg in der schweizerischen
studie übrigens mit der anzahl der
nutzer die sich bei der plattform
vernetzt hatten und ja klar je mehr
daten die user über sich selbst
preisgeben desto sicherer wurde die
prognose zu daten derjenigen die nicht
mal selbst dort angemeldet haben der
schweizerische forscher sagt selbst dass
seine ergebnisse sicher auch auf andere
plattformen wie facebook beispielsweise
zu übertragen sein erfordert deswegen
dass regelungen zum datenschutz dieses
phänomens der schatten profile mehr
berücksichtigt werden müssen aber auch
wir selbst können unsere schlüsse
daraus ziehen denn mittlerweile ist es
oft nicht mehr so dass man apps den
vollen zugriff auf alle daten gewähren
muss an dieser stelle könnte man
beispielsweise die ziele auswählen denn
um das kann sie noch einmal auf den
punkt zu bringen
das recht auf privatsphäre wird hier
komplett ignoriert nicht ich selbst habe
also die entscheidung in der hand
möchte ich persönliche infos
weitergeben oder nicht das entscheidend
stattdessen die anderen für mich und
das auch noch ohne sich darüber im
klaren zu sein und so werde ich darüber
natürlich auch nicht informiert oder
gar um erlaubnis gefragt die chance sich
dagegen zu wehren ist also gleich null
geht gar nicht vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass diese daten sicher nicht
unbedingt vertraulich behandelt werden
und uns allen ist klar daten sind viel
wert nicht umsonst gibt es aussagen wie
daten sind das neue öl und
zahlreiche geschäftsmodelle die daten
für viel geld kaufen gibt es ja
inzwischen zum beispiel für marketing
oder auch politische kampagnen und wenn
plötzlich institutionen wie
krankenkassen behörden oder arbeitgeber
alles aber auch wirklich alles über uns
wissen könnte dass unsere gesellschaft
komplett verändern ja wenn ihr keinen
video zu diesem thema verpassen wollt
und auch zu allen anderen spannenden
themen dann drückt mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht den genau
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
also hier bakterien als datenspeicher
das geht tatsächlich wie dass er vater
im video und ansonsten bis dann bleibt